Speaker 1: Okay. We're going to move on
from Trump's very boring and sweaty and
low energy announcement that he's running
for president. It really was sort of like,
I'm running for president. That
right. Okay, let's move on.
Even Fox News cut away from the speech and they
didn't go back to it for a while. This is super
interesting. At a certain point during the speech,
which was expected to be under a half hour,
Trump went an hour and ranted and raved
about executing drug dealers and so many
other different things. When Trump started talking
about Angela merkel. FOX News just straight up,
cut away his friend Sean HANNITY cutting away.
Speaker 4: Remember I sent to Angler another
angle that you remember, uncle?
Nobody nobody's remembering right now.
Speaker 3: But I'm just joining
us. President Trump in Mar a
Lago announcing his 2024 presidential run.
Speaker 1: Yeah, so HANNITY cutting away.
That was at 9:40 p.m. Eastern Time at 9:44 p.m.,
as you can see here. They still hadn't come back.
They were interviewing Mike Huckabee and that
looks like Pete Hegseth. And then at 9:46 p.m.,
they also didn't come back. They were interviewing
Jim Jordan and oh, I forgot the name of this woman
who was the great Allen Combs sister in law. I
forget her name. That was at 9:46 p.m.. And then
at 9:48 p.m. they were interviewing some guy I
don't recognize and Leo Terrell wearing a Leo 2.0
hat. This is not a good sign for Donald Trump.
And there was a story floating around yesterday
that the Murdochs and Fox News are totally off
the Trump train. It was one of these speculative
but unconfirmed stories. But interestingly
enough, this morning, early this morning,
Maria BARTIROMO, by far one of the biggest brown
noses of Donald Trump now for years, who spread
Trump's conspiracy theories and everything. Even
Maria BARTIROMO this morning, potentially after
seeing the level of lack of energy, rather, at
yesterday's speech. Maria BARTIROMO hosted a
panel all of whom were criticizing Trump and
saying a lot of the stuff Trump is pulling,
we're over as Republicans. Take a look at this.
Speaker 3: That's that's the thing that people
keep pushing back on. They don't want to
go into a whole nother storm of hate. And
there is Trump derangement syndrome, right?
Speaker 2: There's definitely tension. And
I think he started even that last night. He
started with the China virus. He started with,
you know, poking names at DeSantis. We've
heard that and people are tired of it. Look,
I also think that, you know,
DeSantis and Youngkin, like you said,
are really the future of the party. Right.
They're in a generation that I think needs
to come forward in as much as, you know, his
policies were good. Trump's policies within
the first and the first term.
Speaker 4: I don't think the.
Speaker 2: Majority of the country really
wants to go back there. I'll tell you,
I live in Florida. Florida's fully behind
DeSantis. No matter what Trump wants to tell you,
they're fully behind this and this.
Speaker 3: You know, it's interesting.
Ivanka Trump. Ivanka Trump yesterday say she's
bowing out of politics just after her father's
announcement, the former first daughter
telling Fox and she'll be staying out
of the political arena altogether. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So this really is fascinating
because at the end of the day,
you you almost start wondering
how did Trump even end up running? Because the
polling has shifted dramatically towards DeSantis,
who isn't even running for anything at this point.
Not even all of Trump's family wants him to do
this, Ivanka. Not even there. She's bowing out.
You know, I love my father, but sort of stuff.
Maria BARTIROMO seems to now be regularly
entertaining anti-Trump guests. Fox News has
started to do a man on the street interviews
where they happen to come across Republicans
who want DeSantis to be the nominee rather than
Donald Trump. The New York Post, also a News Corp
product, puts out Trump D Dumpty covers last week
making fun of Donald Trump. You start to wonder
who around Trump actually wants him to do this
and where you end up is. It really does seem like
the guy has no friends other than his own ego,
and this is all directed by his own ego. And it
is going to be. I mean, listen, I'll say it. It's
going to be an interesting two years. It also may
be sort of a sad two years. It'll be good for
the country if Trump crashes and burns. But it
also may have some level of sadness. But let's not
assume, like we did in 2015 and 2016, that Trump
can't win because it is very early. It is very
early. Anything can happen to Santos hasn't even
announced anything. And we'll look at the polling
a little bit later in the show. In the meantime,
support the independent, progressive media that
you like. If it's this show, make sure you're
subscribed on YouTube. It's free. Make sure you
subscribe to the podcast. It's free if you want,
sign up it. Join Pacman dot com. If you prefer Sam
Cedar or the Young Turks or Brian Tyler Cohen or
whoever, just make sure you're supporting the
infrastructure so that we are well placed and
well-prepared not to let any of these extremists,
whether it's DeSantis or Trump or whoever,
actually win in 2024. We'll take a
quick break and then be right back